yeah welcome to this video and blitz
five-minute and what let's let's play
the CARICOM I have fun produced those
videos german language for icc and
coronas really good opening like can
usually get by without subjects tense of
theoretical knowledge and still get them
pretty good position okay we've got the
exchange variation here enum really am
yeah very conservative phone for wider
didn't even try to learn to play for for
any sort of advantage okay so try and
form for the minority attack and then
turn it's quite unusual you should to d3
or and you can actually play this with
reverse color so i'm taking that back
it's not unusual i was just irritated a
bit okay maybe he's going before after
this this is a fairly typical way to UM
respond to the minority attack but
doesn't turn seem to be the case here he
just allowed this i mean he you can do
that it's not it's not bad how he how he
played so bush would be five
yeah he's got some pieces on my king i'm
done i didn't want to retreat the light
this i looked really dangerous if I
would retreat probably rookie one yahoo
so I'm carry it looks like him looks
like some attack him hmm how to how to
defend okay I think I need to somehow
get rid of peace and see on the kingside
queen da dum the ideas play 98 maybe I
could have done this zone without moving
the Queen first the thing is he's got
many pieces I'm directed towards the
king but at least at the moment I'm not
seeing how he really am is making um
substantial progress
okay i want to want to exchange Queen g4
maybe yeah okay I am or thinking that
Knight f6 s may be an idea now intending
nagi all nonsense so possible or taking
an IG 70 had this looks really dangerous
what about Bishop f6 Bishop f 62 g
sevens this could be an idea trying to
use come on I need to play move cannot
spend much more time Bishop g7 what's
the idea and maybe I can get the Queen
trade out of this oops oh this is this
is really really really annoying Wow
yeah I completely overlook this of
course and this looks like an looks like
a winner for what hmm
huh yeah this was really bad your foot I
don't don't have a defense um okay and f
the f porn out in the last last hope but
that's probably just just losing
directly to something yeah I should have
played this a bit quicker anyway simply
because there's there's nothing nothing
else I mean this is also losing a but
the other that there was there wasn't
any any alternative at least I suspect
that this is losing but he can probably
just play rookie 61 turn and turn
is it losing instantly probably I
thought rookie 6 was simpler I'm not
checkmated this is much more than I then
I hoped for and in fact this isn't this
isn't so terrible I could have even
taken on c4 and rugae for winning back
the porn would have been been easier
even yeah funny it's it's so it's it's
okay again somehow survived this
probably with lots of lots of luck why
didn't i get the porn back because i'm
stupid right it's really looked like I
was getting the porn back probably found
some weird way to not get it back
guy probably continue I mean of course
it's completely dead this is very rare
usually they play everything on time
rook against rook and whatever of course
I was I was toast yeah I mean I was
close to resign in this position and
maybe this okay computers on plus five
yeah the computer is always very precise
of force in this position slight f4 and
plus 6 yeah yeah now therefore the
problem is after that therefore i can
never move the f born and I need to move
the f porn because of age 7 and this ok
this is also winning now therefore wins
this is also winning Bishop takes 36
wins not yeah this is this region yoga
relatively easy even and this is a I'm
back in the game again listo not made it
not made it and yeah I can I can just
take yeah of course 95 but I thought
this would be more precise but i forgot
about about this move i can just take
the five hunter and it's dead equal yeah
of course it was it was completely
winning for white so very lucky to
escape out of this yeah thanks for
watching